Instructor: We've
learned about lat and const and
what they do, and how they're
scoped, and when they can be
reassigned and when they cannot,
but there's a question as to
what I should actually use
myself. That's a bit of a
hot topic in the community right
now, because some people prefer
to still use var. Some people
are saying, "Var is dead,
entirely." Some people say, "Use
lat." Some people always use
const. I'm just going to go
over two of the leading opinions
here. These are both done by
some very, very smart people in
the JavaScript scene, so I'll
let you pick your own. This
one, by Mathias Bynens, is how I
do it. He talked more about this
like, "Const is not about
immutability where you can
change the properties." We went
over that, but if you scroll
down to the bottom right here,
this is how he uses it, and this
is how I use it. "Use const
by default," so whenever you
make a variable, assume it's
const. "Use let only if
rebinding is needed." Only if
you need to update the value of
your variable, you should use
let. You can use const to keep
it the same value. Then, var
should not be ever used in ES6.
That's sort of what I'm
following. Another popular
opinion here, by Kyle Simpson,
who writes a whole bunch of
awesome JavaScript books is, "
Use var for top level variables
that are shared across many," so
share larger scopes so you can
put them inside of your function. "
Use let for localized variables
in smaller scopes." "Refactor
let to const only after some
code has to be written, and
you're reasonably sure that the
case there shouldn't be a
variable reassign," because that
is bit of a pain with const. If
you realize later that, "Oh, I
do need to update this value,"
you have to go back and make it
a let instead of a const.
Both of those are very valid
opinions. I'll let you make your
own choices on that. Through the
series, I'm going to be
following this advice on this
one.